order
mr. prick me what why me oh I don't care
lack of leadership skills your
disinterest in working with other people
and most importantly the fact that you
went out in such an embarrassingly easy
way better specs here the Devils
ultimate weapon dude you're not the
devil and soda no buddy I serve with the
devil
I knew the devil the devil is a friend
of mine you sir are no devil you didn't
feel right mister sebab what is this
what's with this crazy plan and that
fake dollar store Muppet I just feel
like I'm not as popular as I used to be
what people think I spend all of my time
in elevators and such so I looked up
what people consider to be a cool devil
and everyone pointed to spa wait did you
look up the comic book or the movie
movies ow yeah don't fix you pick the
wrong one that represents the original
source material like Mario Bros the
movie represents the game in fact
there's a petition to get an apology to
tell like what's ammo for both films
well how was I supposed to know you can
tell just by looking at it
based on the popular comic book series
by Tom McFarland fun was made at the
exact worse time it could have been made
where the internet would cast rape this
film for all the inaccuracies to the
source material this was at a time when
comic book movies were taken as
seriously as they are now how do I know
this because it came out the exact same
year as Batman and Robin yeah that's the
kind of Dark Age we're looking at people
prepare for nine circles of suck so this
is what not to do to be a cool devil yes
you better take notes
don't judge me the fill / battle between
the darkness and the light has waged
eternal what was that how was it guy
leave it come on what's going to help
the sequel is along any sequence well
about a month leave is okay it says just
drive by cinema they tell you the back
story the life it takes to pass a
stoplight this was a movie named spawn I
hope you enjoyed it later fight the toys
oh good it looks like things are finally
calming down it's like dynamite in your
ass this is our main character Al
Simmons played by Michael Jai White
who's an assassin who really can't wait
for drones to be made but is still doing
a pretty good job with his implausible
90s technology like him I killed in the
name of good and I've been in better
films now I want but others like me so
after they roll out the seizure credits
hey if I worked on this I'd want my name
to be impossible to see we cut to one of
our villains played by Martin Sheen who
reportedly always want to do a comic
book movie and for his sins
they gave him one all you have to do is
keep certain agencies off my back you
want the big pinata breaks you'll get it
off the other villains are keeping in
shadows even though you quite clearly
showed him a minute ago hmm is called
the violator played by John Leguizamo
thinking evil Sam Kinison if he was
possessed by Krusty the Klown this
5-year plan of yours just tapped my
buttocks anybody here has herpes huh huh
this is a character so evil they
apparently they put him on air
fresheners look what make sure he's back
for dinner tomorrow night
I'll do my best make sure he's back for
dinner tomorrow night Tara you're not
gonna address that huh
no tie-ins no explanation just the
villains faces on an air freshener that
but but yeah okay I mean why should I be
bothered by that it's like if Wolverine
was reading a magazine with magneto on
the cover who needs an explanation pack
I just assume he'll had a successful
side business of dashboard accessories
so don't do that don't act so sinan
seems happy with his wife and kid while
literally slaughtering the competition
but little does he know he's being
watched by a blistering commercial eye
glow when I kill up to 97% plaque
buildup you will follow orders and do
your job and I won out Simmons says he's
done being an assassin though so Sheen
gives him one last job and promises that
he'll let him out safe I mean come on
you can trust a guy who has scorpions in
his ashtray and assistant who carries
tarantulas and literally pictures of
explosions on his wall who does this who
goes that far out of their way for this
kind of crap even Skeletor who lives in
the giant skull is like okay you need to
take it down a notch there buddy but
Simmons is sabotage by Sheen and his
assistant and they cover him in
flammable Nickelodeon's live looks like
I'm up for a promotion he wakes up
confusingly in an alleyway looking like
a salami with Sally Aries face Sela Mary
as he comes across the man who was
watching him before I'm still minty
fresh what are you looking at oh man
this is a dead night you played by
Nicole Williamson and even though he's
every cliched mentor character known to
man he still manages to be a million
flavors of Awesome because he has the
world's coolest voice a new spawn has
emerged from the darkness while things
on earth change in ways that will only
feed his anger and desire
this guy can read the script to beavis
and butt-head and it still sound amazing
and be the smacked Butthead for getting
a better view of a woman's cleavage to
which he replied in vengeful anger cut
it out butthole I'm trying to score but
he must have been a heavy sleeper as
apparently it's five years later and he
doesn't realize that his family has
moved on bad pussy now not like is
unless he's safe as milk that's it just
get your stuff get out of here take him
with you that's the last time we use the
John Wayne Gacy clown registry so
violator is nice enough to bring Simmons
up to speed in the most annoying way
possible of course I guess 5gs feeding
earthworms even what little game there
wasn't there man this is great we
already know he hates clowns but allow
me to kick that young memory so he's
told that when he died five years ago he
was sent straight to hell and oh I'm
sorry that's that's a lot of lame my
army
you can see Walder again yes I'll lead
your army avenge your murder kill Joseph
win
so this is not a good hell that was
really just asked that was really just
asked this is one of the lamest hell's
ever designed not only does it look
beyond fake for a big-budget movie not
only to some of the laziest lay out work
for something that can be creative in
its sleep but this is the shittiest
devil ever literally he looks like a
giant piece of shit if somebody sculpted
a turd to look like a hyena with sea
turtle dicks for ears covered in Ron
Weasley's pubes and the voice of dr.
claw parading as the Lord of Darkness
I'd say what are you smoking give me
some and you're fired
I'd call it a cheap CGI puppet except
it's not even a functioning puppet the
lips don't even move when he talks spawn
keeps is in the bargain
this means that technically the Ninja
Turtle Christmas special had better
effects because they at least made an
attempt to have their lips move this
looks like sarang's pet Chihuahua even
the logic doesn't make any sense
look what's said if simin fails and
leading his army if you fail you dumb
she's already dead he's in hell where
else can you go from there is there a
helper hell is it a place just like this
except the lights flicker and there's a
leaky pipe actually there is a hell for
hell really what is it max on DMV all
right give us up a puss today
so Simmons is shown where he's buried as
he's funny enough right next to a group
of Satan worshipers led by guy fury like
Satan send you guys
how come God hogs up all the good
followers me get all the retards oh I
don't know have you seen Christian
movies lately try Coyle half of it is
mine not didn't look watching work down
for that one why because sometimes in
life that's all you can do oh by the way
just to give you an idea how bad the CGI
is you can actually see where the
glowing effect is cut off no wonder hell
keeps losing they came to figure out how
to crop and effect right what suddenly
Simmons starts to change well you look
better in it than Topher Grace getting
full of Hell's army what am i do no
really what is he done this movie is so
backward Lee told it's impossible to
follow it when I get my hands on when
you're letting them yet you help me
fight gingivitis every choice has its
consequences so he said to kill off
Sheen's character who's tied to a plague
that can wipe out humanity gee I guess
nobody saw that coming as he gets ready
to go to a party that whoa what is she
wearing was there ever any doubt never
see that's what I thought you looked for
an assassin is that what you look like
okay
do you have an assassin who dresses like
that yeah bring her in here I'm gonna
show you how you react when you're
looking for a professional killer
time to load up at haul addict but you
can't turn me down like that anybody who
dresses like that is not gonna take
their job seriously
next what am I supposed to wear armor
bullets like this a best to hide your
face how are people supposed to know
that I'm a woman it doesn't matter if
you're a woman is acting better if they
don't know you're a woman because then
you'll be harder to find crisis
conspicuous as someone from the matrix
wait you didn't like the matrix out but
it was symbolic and messed up yep I'm
gonna put you in contact with a real
professional Betty how fast do you get
down here
I'm already here I like him already
Sheena in the assassinators go to the
party where the dress code seems to be
Green Ranger when Simmons not calling
himself spawn does his first of many
Batman ripoffs wow that so looks like
it's there doesn't it can't you just
feel the texture of the binary code you
don't recognize your handiwork
red skull no that's a different kind of
company I'm bacon skull
nice outfit asshole look who's talking
prostitute it's okay
the camera was just making sure your ass
still looks good it does whoa now that's
a chance to get that working overtime
there's no knockin this cocky the cops
show up and tried to take him down but
spider-ham isn't gonna be caught so
easily set your guns to not even close
his cape disguises him as part of the
building
only to stop using it and have him be
seen again you know for the guy who's
gonna leave the armies of hell he's kind
of a clumsy clod oh come on guys stop
firing at me oh you were so gonna be
enslaved no I'm gonna go tell my weird
Muppet Devil on you gunshot wound to the
head doc she's dead nice delivery there
guy you literally had two words to
saying you couldn't even make those
convincing she's dead
I got to get some ribs you guys want
some ribs I gotta get some ribs I'll
grow up yes nibbling ninny but the
violator call Sheen over to convince him
to attach a device to his heart so that
if it stops beating the plague will be
released we don't want any smartass
fruitcake taking out ahead of schedule
that's a good idea I like that as a
member of hell I know I could trust you
seem like people who would have
explosions on their wall like me that's
trust later right spawn goes to see his
kid who remembers him from earlier but
this scene is especially rush so that we
can make room for funny funny he's out
man
Illinois to the age of lost as this meat
to the age of lost cats to the T to the
ages are okay so far this is the
scariest part of the movie not hell not
weird aardvark Satan this friggin parked
try closing your eyes
it's so disturbing you'll see it even
after they're shot go tell me your
second-in-command doesn't do stuff like
that of course not just wears clown
makeup makes fart jokes and sticks out
like a sore thumb why would that be your
side to the command because it's mmm
wait a minute err hey what's going down
that's so obviously the one from before
now I'm totally a dude see watch I'll
write my name in the snow
see thanks Betty
oh gee it was good back start in Bay
so Shion gets a gig a pet attached to
his heart which rates it so that his
death will set off the virus if your
vital signs flatline for any reason the
device will uplink and detonate the
heat-16 bombs no one would dare kill you
and if you die in an accident or by
natural causes this is why you get
second opinions right first I got Wynn
to kill spawn and create the heat-16
bomb now I get spawn to murder Wynn and
release the virus oh yeah here's an idea
why don't you kill him or your Nintendo
64 devil or any of his followers but why
does bond have to do it nothing about
any of this makes any sense
the logistics of this plan are about a
solid as wily coyotes anatomy and look
about as animated meanwhile spawn
returns to blue lightning alley where
big surprise he gets a little pissed off
with a cloud you can create this army of
yours and jump it I was like a country
song you take their army of your
chinchilla take another from the time he
turns into a giant pumpkin head which
according to 90s logic means he can't
talk anymore he just go rawr and of
course he also loses the personality
we've seen throughout the rest of the
movie why does that kind of thing always
happen in these films is it just not as
intimidating if you hear him go farts
poor confusing cheerleader dance how is
Mario my father yet also my brother he
beats the crap out of spawn but mister
sir Knight is there to show him what he
must do even if he's resistant guns are
useless you got a better idea
yep yep that's pretty stupid I study the
ways of a Woody Woodpecker whoo ha ha ha
so the knight decides to teach him how
to home his powers that a living
extension of your own instincts I doubt
don't get talking have a lot more to
learn well this is obviously the
beginning of a lot of practicing I have
to get the wand just take care of your
powers well so much for the training
montage come on that's the best part of
any movie and you're just gonna skip it
what the hell's wrong with you
what other films did that at the bag
yeah guide if the rock that's enough
works on the wrist doesn't matter even
when it's explained it doesn't make any
sense like what does this mean take care
of your powers when you drain them you
died you didn't even explain the dying
part very well now you're saying is ours
can drain what kind of lame as hell is
this no no it's quite clear when the
powers of hell start to run low just
keep one of the e stands for evil you
know spawn goes after Wanda but keep on
clowning is there to try and stop ah he
must be using his hel driving powers to
steer the truck seriously
does he'll have an instruction book we
can read what's Blanc it's dipped
resulting in violator trying to kill him
but somehow this happens
yeah yeah I kind of keep forgetting how
I work sometimes I can fly sometimes I
don't feel pain really wondering why we
hired you if I could do all this stuff
anyway so Sheen and violator get to
Wanda's house and they hold the family
hostage until spawn gets there
hello cyan me yep
somebody okay that effect folks I think
this will be really underestimates the
value of saying no biggest life and
twice's right I am other leftover
effects for the mask if you like to see
him Oh was that meant to be left in can
it looked like an editing error okay
well I'm just gonna keep walking here
hope you fix that in post if you join
Hills army or she dies so it looks like
Sheen kills Wanda which of course is
supposed to trick spawn into Killian so
spawn takes the device out of his heart
and destroys it just new help our three
six one as it's revealed that Wanda was
just a decoy play by violator you set me
up just counting us spawn killing you
that you would get his soul and
kickstart the apocalypse now yes
I'll rewind that to make sure you heard
it correctly kickstart the apocalypse
now
can I get all of Hell to collectively
boo with me I'm gonna feeling that'd be
a pretty epic boom I don't see why not
the night saves the real Wanda and they
follow violator into hell and yeah if
you thought the effects looked laying
before get a load of this ps1 bullshit
triangle triangle push the triangle
oh I need a character with big boobs
this doesn't feel right there's in the
character with square pixelated boobs
Oh so stabbing them in the neck causes
them to explode Jesus Christ do I need
to take notes
I think mug wise have less rules than
this if you won't leave my army then you
must die what is this guy doing if one
of the sponsors only have a seizure I'm
crazy spawn I'm crazy spawn Oh Devon
escape me Oh drat escape me I'm a really
dumb devil I put no thought into any of
this any of this oh no of course when
you explode into green particles that
just enables you to travel via fireplace
and put yourself together via bookshelf
everybody knows this about Hell you'll
pay for this give my regards to your
boss tell him he's next
I'll slow is rendering to food by
quality to food by quality
don't worry kids blade will be out soon
so nobody know the movie wasn't popular
when they came out what do you thought I
think it's the crowing Darkman sloppy
seconds that's more like the same thing
is there really is good stuff in it like
Lozano is kind of fun the idea is pretty
cool and the makeup in it is friggin
phenomenal these are the same people who
did Walking Dead in two Evil Dead movies
so we know spawn and violator are never
gonna look as good as this which is why
it hurts so much when it's mixed in with
so many awful effects and backwards
storytelling and clumsy editing this
could have been a really damn cool movie
but even when the fight scenes come up
you can so little about why they're
fighting that it becomes so hard to get
invested it's a shame some really hard
work from the costumes and makeup have
to be overshadowed by the crappy
laziness and other departments in an age
where we love to give sequels to
anything you can see clearly why spawn
stands alone so you think you learn what
works and what doesn't work when it
comes to hell think so if I'm going to
take over the world I'm going to do it
by the way that's spirit that was funny
not travel to hell more often citizens
of Earth I am the devil the uprising of
Hell has begun oh yeah I forgot he was
going mad there is no salvation no
pleading for mercy yeah I probably
shouldn't have given him those pointers
prepare to face my army of destruction
we're going to kill you all
look at us
here we are right where we move maybe it
won't be as fast and the Nostalgia
Critic I remember so you don't have to
you
kickstart the apocalypse now
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out and this week we are
doing the Leukemia and Lymphoma Society
also known as LLS this is the world's
largest voluntary health organization
dedicated to funding blood cancer
research education and patient services
their mission is to cure leukemia
lymphoma Hodgkin's disease and improve
the quality of life of patients and
their families since their first funding
in 1954 they've been awarded more than
680 million in research funding if you
look at their YouTube videos you can see
that not only is this organization made
a big difference in people's lives but
the research has even helped save lives
if you go to their site or their YouTube
channel you can see all the good this
charity is doing from fundraising to
triathlons to so much more definitely go
check it out and see if we can find a
cure for these terrible diseases in her
lifetime